Dieser Fund in Südafrika ist wirklich eine
sensationelle Rarität.
Die Rede ist von einem Steinfragment, das
sich jetzt als die ältestes abstrakte Zeichnung
der Menschheit entpuppt hat.
Eine Art “Hashtag” - 73.000 Jahre alt
- bestehend aus roten Linien auf einem Steinfragment.
Forschungsteams sind sich sicher: Diese Malerei
ist mindestens 30.000 Jahre früher entstanden
als alle bisher bekannten Zeichnungen unserer
Vorfahren.
Alle wichtigen Facts zu diesem spannenden
Fund bekommt ihr jetzt - herzlich willkommen
bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Bisher wussten wir, dass schon die Neandertaler
vor 64.000 Jahren Kunst schufen: Beispielsweise
Schmuck und Höhlenmalereien.
Es gibt sogar Hinweise darauf, dass selbst
der Homo erectus Muster in Muschelschalen
geritzt haben könnte - vor unvorstellbaren
500.000 Jahren.
Jetzt gibt es neue Erkenntnisse dazu, um einschätzen
zu können, wann dieser entscheidender Schritt
in der geistigen Entwicklung des Menschen
stattgefunden hat.
Besonderes Augenmerk dabei liegt natürlich
auf dem Homo Sapiens - wann wurde er zum Künstler?
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler hatten
bisher lediglich Höhlenmalereien aus Europa
entdeckt, die etwa 40.000 Jahre alt sind - diese
galten bislang als die ältesten bekannten
Kunstwerke unserer Vorfahren.
Keine Hinweise konnten bisher dazu gefunden
werden, ob der Homo Sapiens mit der abstrakten
Malerei erst nach seiner Auswanderung nach
Europa begann oder ob er diese Fähigkeit
schon in der Urheimat Afrika entwickelt hatte.
Doch mit diesem Rätsel-Raten ist jetzt Schluss.
Denn ein Fund, der bereits vor sieben Jahren
in der sogenannten Blombos-Höhle - etwa 300
Kilometer von Kapstadt entfernt - gemacht
wurde, hat sich jetzt als sensationelle Entdeckung
herausgestellt!
Denn das Steinfragment, das ein Forschungsteam
aus Norwegen ausgegraben hatte, ist verziert
mit einer Zeichnung.
Zumindest im weitesten Sinne.
Konkret wurden auf dem Steinstück neun Linien
entdeckt - vier davon bilden Raute.
Eine Art Hashtag also!
Die anderen der mit Ocker gemalten Linien
kreuzen sich zum Teil beziehungsweise verlaufen
parallel.
Die Untersuchungen des Forschungsteams haben
jetzt ergeben, dass sowohl die Linien als
auch der Stein wohl etwa 73.000 Jahre alt
sind.
Somit sind die Muster auf diesem Stein mindestens
30.000 Jahre früher entstanden als die bisher
bekannten Malereien des Homo Sapiens - und
stellen damit die wohl älteste bekannte abstrakte
Malerei der Menschheit dar.
Zudem ist sicher: Der Stein wurde durch Menschen
in seine Form gebracht und mit Ockerpigment
angemalt.
Dazu heißt es in der Untersuchung: "Die Breite
der Linien spricht dafür, dass sie mit einem
Ockerstift mit 1,3 bis 3,3 Millimeter breiter
Spitze gezeichnet wurden.
Das abrupte Enden aller Linien an den Kanten
des Steinfragments zeigt zudem, dass sich
dieses Muster ursprünglich über eine größere
Oberfläche erstreckte – das Muster war
wahrscheinlich noch komplexer und strukturierter
als auf diesem Bruchstück erkennbar."
Und für die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
ist auch klar, dass diese Muster nicht durch
Zufall bei einer anderen Tätigkeit unserer
Vorfahren entstanden sind.
Stattdessen handele es sich tatsächlich um
“echte” Zeichnungen, die mit voller künstlerischer
Ambitionen auf den Stein gemalt wurden.
Dazu das Forschungsteam: “Das Zeichnen war
demnach schon vor 73.000 Jahren Teil des Verhaltensrepertoires
des frühen Homo sapiens in Südafrika”.
Und nicht nur das: Das Forschungsteam hat
weitere Ockerstückchen identifiziert.
Und auch dort sind ähnliche Muster eingeritzt.
Auch das lässt spannende Schlüsse auf die
geistige Entwicklung unserer Vorfahren zu.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Christopher
Henshilwood: “Der frühe Homo sapiens nutzte
demnach schon verschiedene Techniken, um grafische
Muster auf unterschiedlichen Medien zu erschaffen”.
Hammer!
Es ist immer wieder spannend sich all diese
Ereignisse und wann sie stattfanden vor Augen
zu halten.
Wann lebten die Dinosaurier, wann die mammuts,
wann besiedelten wir Europa?
Wer sind unsere Vorfahren.
Ständig gibt es dazu neue Erkenntnisse!
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert auch den englischen Kanal von
Clixoom, denn auch da gibt es Videopremieren.
Dafür hier klicken und hier geht es weiter
mit: Mystery of the alien mummy revealed Ich
hoffe wir sehen uns auf dem englischen Kanal.
Stay tuned see you soon!